-Welcome, everybody! Welcome
Please, have a seat,
enjoy yourself.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You guys,
I'm excited about this.
Dave Grohl
is my co-host tonight!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Dave, if things go well here
this could be the big brea
you've been waiting for.
-Oh, you think so?
-Yes. Yes.
-Yeah, no. I'm really --
I'm really happy to be here.
This is definitely
one of the coolest things
that I've done today.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-No, of course not.
I was in Nirvana.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, let's get to some news.
Guys, here's some good new
to kick things off.
COVID cases in the U.S.
have dropped to the lowest level
in almost a year.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Pretty soon, the only plac
you'll see Dr. Fauci
is popping out of a costum
on "The Masked Singer."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Things are really coming back.
Audiences are back.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Restaurants are back!
-Kevin Spacey is back.
-No, Dave, no, no.
Dave, no, no.
-That's not --
-No, no, no, no, no.
-I thought --
-We'll cut that later.
We'll cut that later. Well
as the pandemic is calming down,
I heard that retailers
are having a hard time unloading
all of the hand sanitizer
that they stocked up on
over the past year.
Right now, the CEO of Purell
and the CEO of Zoom
are just holding
each other crying.
[ Both imitating crying ]
-You know, the best hope
that Purell has
to unload their product
at this point
is turning it into
Purell Hard Seltzer.
-Yeah, I'd drink it.
-Yeah.
-I'd drink that.
-I'd drink Purell.
-[ Laughs ]
I want to say congrats
to Phil Mickelson
on winning the PGA Championshi
at the age of 50...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...becoming the oldest golfe
to claim a major title.
-Yeah, finally, inspiratio
for older men everywhere
that golf is a sport
they can pursue.
-Yeah. Amazing. Yeah,
after he sunk his putt on 18
he used a grabber claw
to get the ball out of the cup
[ Laughter ]
The fans were going
so crazy for Mickelson,
he actually needed
a security escort
on the green, the final hole
Watch this.
-Kiawah erupts.
[ Crowd cheering ]
-Actually, they've lost contro
of the scene. Yeah.
-God. It looked like the annua
running of the khakis.
[ Laughter ]
-Those people haven't
been that excited
since Lexus had
their December to Remember
[ Laughter ]
I'm just glad to see
a mob of white people
who aren't storming the Capitol.
Aren't you --
[ Oohs and applause ]
Do you want -- Yeah --
-No, I don't want --
-You want to read that joke?
-No, it's all you.
That's all you, Jimmy. Yeah,
switching gears, I just sa
that Pop-Tarts just released
a brand-new mystery flavor
-Oh. It sounds fun
until you realize
the mystery flavor is cicada
[ Laughter, groaning ]
Hey, guys, I want to say
happy birthday to Bob Dylan,
who turns 80 years old today
-Come on, Bob.
-My man!
-That's right, Bob Dylan is 80
which means he still
has a decent chance
at winning the Super Bowl
or a major golf tournament
That's what it means.
I heard that Timothée Chalamet
will play a young Willy Wonk
in a new origin story film
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he's officially
made the jump
from "Little Women"
to "Little Wonka."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's the magical story
of a young Willy Wonka
right before he grew up
and tried to murder
all those kids.
-Oh, yeah. Odd plot.
[ Laughter ]
Some more celebrity news -
On CBS yesterday,
Martha Stewart was sharing tip
on organizing your kitchen
but this is good.
Something stood out to me
when she got to her
knife drawer. Watch this.
-Another organizational ti
for all of you
is to make a knife drawer.
You want to see
the best knife I have?
-Oh!
-Look at that one.
-Man.
-And it was signed by me.
-Then she just stared
into the camera for 30 seconds
[ Sinister music plays ]
I don't care what you say --
[ Applause ]
Prison's changed Martha.
-Yeah.
-Gnarly. Finally, a drug deale
in the UK was tracked down
after police identified hi
through his fingerprints
in a photo of cheese
he posted online.
Here's the photo.
[ Laughter ]
-Police found 20 kilos of heroin
and 50 kilos
of multigrain Wheat Thins.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's my favorite one.
After seeing the evidence,
his lawyer said,
"This is not gouda."
[good]
You can do those jokes --
-Nope, that's --
This is your show, dude.
Yeah. On the bright side,
in prison --
-He'll age nicely
for the next 10 to 15 years!
Today, the White House announced
that President Biden
will have his first
one-on-one meeting
with Vladimir Putin
on June 16th.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yeah.
It's a nice reminder that,
after a year in quarantine
you're going to have to se
some people you don't like
[ Laughter ]
I can't wait to see
how these two guys
try to out-macho each othe
during the summit.
It's like, "I don't need
a bathroom break. Do you?"
[ Laughter ]
[ As Putin ]
No, in fact, let's take of
our shirts
and have a pec-flexing contest
[ Laughter ]
Yep, this will be
their first in-person meetin
since Biden told Putin,
"I don't think you have a soul."
[ Laughter ]
It's going to be fun
when Putin tells Biden --
[ As Putin ]
Say once more so I can use
for outgoing voicemail.
[ Laughter ]
And go now.
Say now.
The meeting will be part
of Biden's first foreign tri
as president.
He'll roll up like every other
American in Europe --
fanny pack, selfie stick,
and a love for saying,
"Hey, they have a McDonald's."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it'll be Biden's
first foreign trip as president,
and let's hope
it's just as satisfying
as his first domestic trip
Whoop.
-Whoa!
-Oh.
Hey, oh!
[ Cymbals crash ]
-Whoa!
-Like four trips in one
on that one, right there, yeah
-Oh.
-Well, here's some good news
As of today,
half of all adults in the U.S.
are now fully vaccinated.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Applause ]
That's right.
Half of America is vaccinated,
while the other half
uses Facebook.
[ Laughter, applause, and ohhs ]
-Yikes.
-That's right, 50%.
So basically,
one Johnson is vaccinated,
the other Johnson isn't.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Well, if people need yet another
incentive for the vaccine,
United Airlines is offerin
its vaccinated customers
the chance to win
a year of free travel.
That's right.
United's first prize
is a year of free travel, whil
the second prize is two years.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm good. I'm good."
Hey, I saw that
Mike and Karen Pence
just bought a new house
right outside of Indianapolis.
At first, Karen thought
the house was haunted,
but it was just Mike
stepping out of the shower
[ Laughter ]
"You really are white, wow
I can see through you, yeah.
He's translucent. Unbelievable."
[ As Pence ] It's more
of a frosted-glass look.
[ Laughter ]
Get this. In Georgia,
officials are asking residents
to stop calling 911
about cicadas.
[ Laughter ]
Stop it.
Stop calling 911
about cicadas.
Which backfired immediatel
when a bunch of cicadas
robbed a 7-Eleven.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in Texas,
a woman decided to do somethin
pretty crazy at the El Paso Zoo.
Watch this.
-A zoo in Texas is trying
to track down the woman
caught on video inside
the spider monkey exhibit.
She reportedly hopped a barrie
at the El Paso Zoo
so she could feed the monkey
Hot Cheetos.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't worry.
After the incident,
the woman was quickly returned
to her own enclosure.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, people were shocked,
while the monkeys were like,
"Carl, your Uber Eats is here.
[ Applause ]
♪♪♪♪
This is big.
Today, President Biden
gave U.S. intelligence agencie
90 days to find out exactl
how COVID started.
Yep. Biden was like --
[ As Biden ]
If you can find a fiancé
in 90 days,
you can find the truth
about COVID.
[ Laughter ]
I believe that.
It's worth a shot. I mean,
if we've learned anything
from Marvel movies,
everyone loves
a good origin story, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And I'm excited,
'cause they've already cas
Timothée Chalamet
to play young COVID.
[ Laughter ]
So that's going to be cool
Yep, Biden wants
the COVID origin story now
Then, in 10 years, he want
a COVID reunion on HBO Max
[ Laughter ]
I'm pretty sure this will en
with us tracing COVID
back to the same lab
that came up with the McRib.
[ Laughter ]
I love this.
It's in the shape of a rib
isn't it?
-Ribbish.
-Ribbish, right?
Like, bone-in?
-Eh, no.
It looks like a bone-in rib.
-Like, it looks like the thing
that flipped over
Fred Flintstone's car.
-Exactly.
That big, like a bronto-rib.
-I love it.
Here's some more big news.
Last night, it came out
that a grand jury
is hearing evidence
against former President Trump
and could indict him.
-Ooh.
-Yep.
Trump knew he was in trouble
when he called his lawyer
and the FBI
answered Rudy's phone.
[ Laughter ]
"You're being recorded."
We know a trial is close
when the courtroom sketch artist
goes to Michael's and says
"Give me all the orange crayon
you have.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's going down.
It's going down."
[ Applause ]
Of course,
Trump responded to the news.
In his official statement,
he said...
Then he added...
[ Laughter ]
And finally, he said...
I have to catch a flight
to Mexico."
[ Laughter, cheering, applause ]
He's innocent.
Some news from the UK.
Apparently, at the start
of the pandemic, British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson
wanted to be injected
with COVID on live TV
so people could see there'
nothing to be scared of.
[ Laughter ]
Once again, no good idea
has ever started with,
"I'm going to inject myself.
[ Laughter ]
Boris was like --
[ As Johnson ]
In hindsight, it was stupid.
[ Laughter ]
And then opened a Starbuck
bathroom door with his mouth
"Aaaah!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
as we head into summer,
I read that there's alread
a big shortage of fireworks.
-Ooh.
-That's not good,
'cause the only thing wors
than mixing booze and firework
is mixing booze
and bootleg fireworks.
That's what I say.
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know
what the heck it does.
Just light it.
[ Laughter ]
Don't go near it!
All right.
One selfie -- that's it.
Then don't touch it!
Oh, look,
the dog's playing with it.
Oh, that's fun.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Take it out of his mouth."
Some guys are going to be like
"Well, I guess we could just
deep-fry a turkey
and hope for the worst."
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
In Virginia, a man created
a COVID-safe way
for people to --
I love inventions.
-Yeah.
-I love inventions.
-You do.
-They're my favorite.
I really do.
So, this man in Virginia
created a COVID-safe way
for people to blow out
birthday candles
by inventing a device
that's called the Blowzee.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's a good idea,
but I'm not sure I want the word
Blowzee showing up
on my credit-card statement.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
And get this -- I read that over
$1 million worth of cocain
tied to life jackets
washed up on a beach in England.
Police got to work on the case
while the SyFy Channel
got to work on "Cocaine Shark.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'd watch --
I'd watch "Cocaine Shark."
-Yeah.
-Finally, new research estimates
that the oldest maximum ag
humans can live is 150 years
Right now, there's
a 149-year-old who's like,
"I thought I'd have more time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Today is the day everybody
The "Friends" reunion
is now available on HBO Max.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And just like every reunion,
people were mainly excited
to see who gained
the most weight.
And it's Marcel.
-Is it really?
-You wouldn't
even recognize him.
The thing is so huge, though
HBO Max is already plannin
a "Friends Reunion:
The Reunion."
-Yeah.
-Really?
Each cast member was paid
$2.5 million for the special
[ Audience ohh's ]
Meanwhile, when he heard,
Gunther was like,
"You guys got paid?
They told me
this was just for fun."
$2.5 million is a lot.
I mean, for that kind of money
you can almost subscribe
to HBO Max and Netflix.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. The "Friends
reunion is a big success,
and it looks like HBO Max
has even more plans
for the franchise.
Check this out.
-From the people
who brought you "Friends,"
coming soon to HBO Max, it's..
...the story of a little
bald boy who dreams of someday
making cappuccinos
for hot 30-somethings.
-I don't know
if that's going to work.
[ Applause ]
Some more entertainment news
Amazon just reached a deal
to buy MGM Studios
for $8 billion.
Yeah, at this point,
the only thing Jeff Bezos
doesn't own is hair.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Amazon owns
the "James Bond" franchise
The creators of "James Bond"
said there won't be
any obvious changes,
except there's one scene
where Bond orders
two martinis
and then drunk-shops on Amazon
-[ Laughter ]
-But check this out.
I saw that CVS is now
offering prizes for people
who get vaccinated
in their pharmacies.
Some of the prizes
are pretty great,
especially the grand prize -
the key to the locked case
where they keep all
the razors and deodorant.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Meanwhile, last night,
Ohio announced
the first two winners
of its Vax-a-Million lottery
Yep, any vaccinated adult
was eligible to win $1 million
That's pretty crazy,
but Ohio isn't the only stat
offering incentives
to vaccinated residents.
Check out what you could win
in other states.
First up, if you get vaccinate
in Vermont, they'll let you...
Big spoon, little spoon.
Your choice.
Up next, if you're vaccinate
in South Dakota,
you're eligible to...
-Room for one more!
-Ah. Next up,
if you get vaccinated
in Florida, you can...
[ Applause ]
Actually, you can do that,
no matter what.
It's a right in Florida.
And, finally, if you get
vaccinated in Georgia,
they'll let you...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, this is very interesting
A new feature
just became available
on Instagram and Facebook
that allows users to hide likes.
No more likes?
In response,
everyone canceled their brunch
and gave away their babies
[ Laughter ]
"I'm not in it for that.
I'm not in it for that."
Listen to this.
I heard that Walmart is
working with Gap to launch
a new home-goods brand
called Gap Home.
That's right.
Walmart home décor.
It's the only place
you can get an Ottoman
with a lower-back tattoo.
[ Laughter ]
I saw that a McDonald's
in Illinois came up with
a creative way
to recruit new employees.
Look at this,
the sign they put out there.
It says,
"Now hiring. Free iPhone
after six months' employment
and meet criteria."
Owner's gonna be thrilled
with his new employees
until the first day
of month seven.
[ Laughter ]
Some giant culinary news here.
I saw that DiGiorno
is coming out with a new
limited-edition
doughnut pizza mash-up
called the DiGiornut.
Here it is.
[ Audience groans ]
"It's not delivery.
It's disgusting."
It's perfect if you thought yo
hit rock bottom with Bagel Bites
but still wanted to dig
a little deeper.
And, finally,
a skydiver in California
missed his landing zone
and wound up getting caugh
in some power lines.
Take a look at this.
[ Audience ooh's ]
The good news is his Apple Watch
is charged for
the next seven years.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Well, guys, the weekend
kicks off
the unofficial start of summer
That's right,
happy Memorial Day
-Yeah!
-to all of you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Happy Memorial Day
to all of you,
except for that guy
in your office
who sent a work email
at 4:59 pm.
You go, "No, we're not reading
it, Carl."
I have a feeling people
are going to really
let loose this weekend.
Don't you have that feeling?
[ Cheering ]
By this time tomorrow,
the cornhole boards
will just be two guys passed out
with their mouths open.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
According to AAA,
nearly 40 million people
are expected to travel 50 mile
or more this weekend.
When asked where they're
going, everyone said, "Anywhere.
Literally. Anywhere else."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, with so
many people traveling
this weekend, gas prices
are expected to skyrocket.
Yeah, the bad news is gas
is expensive.
But good news is you'll have
something to talk about
with your father-in-law.
[ Laughter ]
"Can you believe
how expensive the gas --"
Gas is so expensive,
when I filled up this morning,
a guy in a tux was like,
"Might I recommend
the Sunoco 92?"
[ Laughter ]
That sounds good.
"Excellent choice,
Mr. Fallon."
Speaking of traveling,
a new survey finds
that the majority of Americans
won't take a road trip
without the perfect playlist
And 35% said they'd turn the car
around if they didn't have one
[ Laughter ]
What's more troubling is only 8%
said they'd turn the car aroun
if they forgot
one of their kids.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-"Ah, he doesn't listen
to my music anyway."
Yeah, you spend days
making the perfect playlist,
then you spend the whole tri
trying to connect
your phone
to the car's Bluetooth.
It's really fun.
[ Laughter ]
"Alright, everyone turn
their Bluetooth off!
Everyone turn --
Now I got to pull over.
Here we go.
Then we're going to have fun
Then we'll have fun.
Everyone turn it off!"
Get this -- according to the
National Hot Dog
and Sausage Council...
[ Laughter ]
...73% of Americans believ
that a barbecue
is not complete
without hot dogs.
I think the bigger story her
is that we have
a National Hot Dog
and Sausage Council.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-Send me a T-shirt, man.
-Number one.
-A lot of Americans are goin
to barbecues this weekend.
And sometimes you have
good barbecues.
Sometimes you have bad ones,
so we actually came up
with some clues, some warnings
to help you guys realize
that you're at a bad one.
So if you see this --
For example, if you're at --
you're at a bad barbecue if...
[ Audience ohs ]
That's disgust-- that's gross.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Here we go, this warning here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That means you're
at a bad barbecue.
-That's a bad one?
-This is a bad one, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Here's another warning --
bad one.
-Okay.
-Don't have him burp
by the grill. Yeah.
Also, here's another warning
[ Audience ohs ]
-Oh.
-That was a mixed reaction
Someone out there likes it
[ Laughter ]
Someone likes that.
-Is that real?
-I'm not afraid of it.
I'll try it.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, warning,
Just some warning signs.
Just a couple.
If you see those, just know.
Well, changing gears,
today Senate Republicans
voted to block
the January 6th commission
that would investigate
the Capitol riots.
[ Audience booing ]
After the vote, Republican
said they'll gladly explai
their decision in an upcomin
QAnon -- I mean Q&A.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
That's a great crowd.
Senate Republicans said they'd
rather investigate
something more important, like
why wasn't Paul Rudd
in the "Friends" reunion?
Come on!
[ Cheering and applause ]
That makes more sense.
Here's some good news.
Right here this weekend
all New York beaches
will be open,
and vaccine buses
will be stationed
on a few of them.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And just to make sure
they attract a crowd,
all the vaccine buses
will play the Mr. Softee jingle.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the vaccine buses
are a great idea
because, when they're done
they can just toss the needles
on the beach
with all the others.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ New Jersey accent ]
Hey, what are you gonna do
[ Laughter ]
Come on. We're at the beach!
-"Hey, I'm with
the Sausage Council!"
-That's right. We work
for the Sausage Council.
What he said.
[ Laughter ]
Another sign that
we're returning to normal --
Costco is bringing back
their free samples.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Don't worry, though.
They're still being careful.
Now a Costco employee
will just slingshot
a cheese cube into your mouth.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news --
American Airlines
just announced that they'r
partnering with Rosetta Ston
to offer language courses
to passengers during flights
-Ooh.
-You think someone kicking
your seat is tough,
imagine sitting next to some guy
sounding out French
for six hours.
[ Laughter ]
"Bonj-- bonjoi-- Bonjoar?
Aurevware? Aurvware. Aurvwar
Aurvwar. Aurvwar.
Aurvwar. Bonjar.
Bonjar. Aurvoir. Jonbar."
John Bar Jarvoir, everyone
[ Laughter ]
Love him.
That's right.
The airline's also offerin
courses like photography.
So, if flying
isn't awkward enough,
just wait till a stranger'
snapping photos of you sleeping.
[ Laughter ]
"You looked
beautiful and peaceful."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this made me laugh.
Yesterday a CNN reporter
was preparing for a live sho
when he realized
a cicada was on him.
Take a look at this.
-Am I going to be in the -
in the same block out of thi
or going to take a break?
Okay.
[ Audience ohs ]
Oh!
Oh, my God!
[Bleep]
[Bleep] cicada.
[ Laughter ]
-Everyone in the control roo
was like --
they just sat back there like,
"Let's just see how this -
[ Laughter ]
Let's see how this plays out
Let's not say anything."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of cicadas,
a photographer in Virginia
has recently picked up
an interesting new hobby.
Check this out.
-We started with my
son's fire truck.
I decided to do
a cicada rock band.
This cicada is doing archery
[ Laughter ]
This cicada was lifting.
Look, Ping-Pong.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, so clearly not everyone
made it
through quarantine, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-Ping-Pong.
-Guys, finally, as I mentioned
Monday is Memorial Day,
and people are excited
to go to barbecues again.
I love a good
old-fashioned potluck,
where everyone brings a side
but there's nothing worse
than when no one wants
to eat your side.
Here, let me explain
with a "Tonight Show" Tiny Song.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ It's my first barbecue
in two years ♪♪
♪♪ Can't wait to see my friend
and crack some beers ♪♪
♪♪ Dave brought fruit sala
Anne brought rum lemonade
♪♪ But no one's touched
the thing that I made ♪♪
♪♪ Somebody eat my carrot slaw
♪♪ Please, somebody eat
my carrot slaw ♪♪
♪♪ Heard someone ask, "Hey
what's that supposed to be?" ♪
♪♪ Glad my grandma's not
'cause it's her recipe ♪♪
♪♪ Somebody eat my carrot slaw
♪♪ Somebody eat
my carrot slaw ♪♪
♪♪ No one put it on their plat
even though I'm right here ♪
♪♪ Saying, "Doesn't
this look great? ♪♪
♪♪ Now, I'm leaving the party
♪♪ Can't look people in the eye
♪♪ So I'll just throw it
in my freezer ♪♪
♪♪ Till the 4th of ♪♪
♪♪ July ♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]